[Music]
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number we're gonna go
to next to our caller from the three
three zero area code caller from three
three zero introduce yourself hi David
my name's Rob caller from Akron Ohio
awesome Rob what's going on not much
I wanted to ask what's your thoughts on
our in terms of how we discuss fiscal
spending in America because it seems to
me the more I listen to Stephanie tell
in and the more you know I buy into my
own monetary theory and I get the
understanding that if the country is
truly a sovereign issuer of currency
that we don't necessarily have any real
limits on what we can do in spending in
terms of the federal level it seems to
me when politicians get into oh we can't
afford this we can't afford that we'd
have to raise taxes here we have to
raise taxes there that they're being a
little disingenuous if we are in the
sovereign issuer of currency that don't
have to limit ourselves on the on the
federal level so what are your thoughts
on that
yeah so I've been reading a lot about
modern monetary theory earlier this week
we actually interviewed economist
Pavlina Chernova who's very
knowledgeable on that issue and
stephanie kelton who you mentioned is
scheduled to be on with us in the next
couple weeks so we're taking that issue
seriously and yes I mean you're you're
right which is aside from so you can you
can believe modern monetary theory or
not believe that it accurately describes
sort of the relationship to the creation
of currency by governments but what's
clear is that our elected officials are
completely disingenuous when it comes to
the use of the debt as a reason not to
do things and then ignoring debt when
they want to do something like provide
tax cuts to the very rich there's it and
to say disingenuous it's both
disingenuous and there's probably some
level of incompetence as well I would
never say it's only disingenuine when
incompetence is is also there but yeah I
think there's a lot to what you're
saying and you'll probably like our
interview with Stephanie coming up yeah
I think I will like it and I just find
it really ironic that Trump of all
people you know as incompetent as he can
be yeah actually broach this subject
completely by accident maybe about a
year
now he says something along the lines
that we can spend what we want because
we print the money I mean it's a bit
more complex than that but through
complete accident you know it seems like
he was like the most accurate on the
subject yeah it just kind of makes me
laugh out loud trust me that person and
there was anything about fiscal policy
it was completely by accident that we
can be absolutely sure no no I think
Trump was ahead of his time on this one
really
yeah throne visit the Trump's
knowledgeable about modern monetary
theory that's a good one yeah great
points Rob good topic and we're gonna
we're going to talk about that coming up
sounds good I look forward to the
interview with Stephanie okay great
thanks so much for the call appreciate
it